Hello, Rick.
Hello, Louis.
How extravagant you are, throwing away women like that.
Someday, they may be scarce.
You know, I think now I shall pay a call on Yvonne, maybe get her on the rebound, huh?
When it comes to women, you're a true democrat.
If he gets a word in, it'll be a major Italian victory.
The plane to Lisbon.
You would like to be on it?
Why? What's in Lisbon?
The clipper to America.
I've often speculated on why you don't return to America.
Did you abscond with the church funds?
Did you run off with a senator's wife?
I like to think that you killed a man.
It's the romantic in me.
It's a combination of all three.
And what in heaven's name brought you to Casablanca?
My health. I came to Casablanca for the waters.
The waters? What waters?
We're in the desert.
I was misinformed.